this week's episode is brought to you in
part by the American Dental Association
teeth tell a story we know what ancient
civilizations ate drank even where they
lived all from looking at their teeth
what story will your teeth tell about
you your ad a dentist can help you find
out and give you the tools to keep your
teeth healthy for years to come
use the American Dental Association's
find a dentist tool to find the right
dentist for you go to ata org slash
science mag today welcome to the science
podcast for November 9 2018 I'm Sara
Crespi in this week's show I talk with
online news editor David Grimm about a
rise in research using monkeys and
Meghan Cantwell talks with news writer
Adrienne Chow about the upcoming changes
to standards for measurement like the
metre and the kilogram alright well now
we have David Grimm online news editor
for science and we're gonna talk about
monkey research on the rise so Dave what
have you found out about increases in
the use of non-human primates by
researchers in the US well the USDA the
United States Department of Agriculture
recently released its usage statistics
so basically USDA tracks the number of
animals used in biomedical research
every year and they post a report and
this year's report been discovered 2017
is showing a record high number of
non-human primates and that essentially
means monkeys in this case being used in
biomedical research about 76,000 which
is the highest it seems to have ever
been and the trends have been inching
upwards for the last last few years so
what proportion of animal research is
comprised of these non-human primates it
was actually a pretty small percentage
about 0.5 percent the vast majority of
animals used in research are mice and
rats although they are not recorded by
USDA because they're not covered by the
Animal Welfare Act so we don't have data
on them but we have data on animals like
cats dogs guinea pigs rabbits things
like that and all those animals are
lower levels and they were 10 years ago
and only the monkeys are at higher
than there were ten years ago I'm sure
there's a lot of speculation on why
these numbers are going up and one of
them must be they're needed for
particular kinds of research what kinds
of research are people increasingly
using monkeys for right and you know
that's what a lot of the biomedical
research advocates are saying that these
these animals are really needed more
than ever
you know we've got emerging infectious
diseases like Zika we're really starting
to get a better understanding of the
brain things like Alzheimer's even
developing things like interfaces where
the brain can control prosthetics and
all those things they say a really
require monkey research is not the kind
of research you could do in a rat or a
rabbit or anything like that what about
drug research I mean there's this
business translation problem for so long
and mice and rats have been considered
the culprit do researchers think that
monkeys are gonna help close that gap
yeah that's what they say they say you
know the reason that the vast majority
of drugs at work in rodents don't work
and humans is because they're so
different than us and non-human primates
like monkeys are so similar to us
genetically biologically the argument is
that we should be testing you know
making more of an effort to make sure
the drugs working them before they go on
into human studies in you know because
we're trying to develop all these drugs
for things like depression Alzheimer's
things that really deal with the brain
and you want an animal whose brain is
pretty similar to ours they're saying
these animals are really going to be
needed you know more than ever and you
know in fact National Institutes of
Health is saying that the demand for
monkeys is really going to probably
increase over the next few years just
because of things like this usually when
you and I talk about research animals
we're talking about chimps because
there's been so many regulations put in
place on their use in the US and then
that hasn't been happening with monkeys
at all is that somehow a trade-off that
might have occurred that's a good
question you know there there is
actually no biomedical research on
chimps allowed anymore in the u.s. so
all chimpanzees are still in labs or
theoretically on their way to being
retired and the way that we got there
was you know NIH commissioned a report a
few years back that really was asking
tough questions about whether we really
needed chimpanzees and biomedical
research and the report came conclusion
that we did that they really hadn't
proved to be they're useful model that
we thought they were and it wasn't just
it wasn't worth the cost to use them and
so a lot of animal guide because they're
saying we should really do the same
thing with monkeys we really need to
take a hard
look at weather just because we think
these animals are gonna be better for
biomedical research they're saying that
we really need to take a hard look at
these animals and figure out are they
really better will they really solve
this reproducibility crisis this
translate ability crisis or are they
destined for the same path as
chimpanzees where we're eventually gonna
see a phase-out these animals as well so
we should really mention which kinds of
monkeys that are being used in their
research what what are you know what are
the most common monkey research animals
yeah the most common arm attacks
especially rhesus macaques animals like
baboons make up a very small percentage
so it's mostly it's mostly various
species of macaque we can't not mention
marmosets there was another story a week
or two ago about there used in research
and how that's been changing right and
the interesting story with marmoset
switch actually only make up a pretty
small fraction of the monkeys being used
right now but they're really becoming a
demand for a lot of genetic research a
lot of transgenic animal research and
the idea is the demand is actually so
high for Mormons that's right now that
it we can't the US cash we can beat
supply and some biomedical researchers
are worried the same thing is starting
to happen for other monkeys as well like
rhesus macaques that because the demand
for you know cures for AIDS and
Alzheimer's and things like that is so
high that we actually don't as many
monkeys as we're using we actually may
need more and all we are there enough
available for the type of research that
scientists want to do so we kind of have
a bunch of different things happening
we're seeing a lot more use of monkeys
in research even perhaps demand
outstripping supply and then there are
people who are not happy about this and
who are probably gonna try the same
route that they took for chimps so
what's next well some of the animal
advocacy groups really want Congress to
put pressure on agencies like the NIH
really forced them to take a hard look
at these types of studies and whether
they're really needed on the other hand
biomedical researchers said you know the
public wants cures I mean the public has
made it clear they want yours for AIDS
they want cures for Alzheimer's they
want cures for depression and they and
they're basically saying the public
can't have it both ways you know yes
if you guys want these cures we're gonna
need to use these animals so you know
this is that this is a fight that's
likely to probably get worse
in the coming years alright thank you so
much Dave thanks Sarah
David Grimm is the online news editor
for science you can find a link to his
story at news that science bank org stay
tuned for Meghan kee awaaz interview
with Adrienne Chow on upcoming changes
to international standards on
measurement this episode is also brought
to you in part by opps Jeannie
incidents happen and they require
complex coordination between operations
and software development teams who are
putting out fires every day that's why
getting alerts immediately is critical
thankfully there's ops Jeannie bye
Atlassian ops Jeannie empowers dev and
ops teams to plan for service
disruptions and stay in control during
incidents it also gives teams the power
to respond quickly and efficiently to
unplanned issues and helps to notify all
the right people through a smart
combination of scheduling and escalation
paths that account for things like time
zones and holidays better yet ops
Jeannie allows for deep flexibility and
how when and where alerts are deployed
with over 200 integrations like JIRA
Amazon CloudWatch data dog New Relic
and more plus attracts all activity and
provides useful insights to improve
future incident responses with ops
Jeannie your next incident doesn't stand
a chance
visit ops Jeannie comm to sign up to get
a free company account and add up to
five team members that's ops Jeannie
comm Oh PS GE n IE comm never miss a
critical alert again with ops Jeannie
[Music]
this episode is also brought to you in
part by the NSA almost every day we hear
something on the news about a
cyberattack sometimes it's just some
pranksters but more often it's a foreign
country with vast cyber resources trying
to hack the power grid the banking
system or the military's information
networks the National Security Agency
plays a big part in protecting the
country from cyberattacks and you could
help the NSA is hiring technical
professionals to serve on the front
lines of information security if you
work in computer science networking
programming or electrical engineering
you can help keep the country safe
design new hardware systems and networks
right faster smarter programs protect
America's critical infrastructure or
help uncover when its adversaries are
planning to do next learn more about
careers at the National Security Agency
today visit intelligence careers gov
slash NSA that's intelligence careers
gov slash NSA for a vast majority of the
world excluding the u.s. Burma and
Liberia the metric system is the
official system of measurements and
weights staff writer Adrian Cho is here
to talk about how an upcoming meeting in
France the 26th General Conference on
weights and measurements which occurs
about every four years may shake up how
we define measurements that have been
used for hundreds of years
hey Adrian hi me again how are you doing
well how are you very good so this is
the 26th conference that's being held
are they're usually significant changes
that occur two units every single time
they meet well usually there's either a
proposal to change something or there is
an update up but this one is a pretty
significant one in that not only are
they changing say one specific unit but
they're reekin sexualizing the entire SI
system what are the units that are set
to be redefined or reekin sexualized so
there are seven base units in the SI
system and four of them are going to be
redefined and those are the kilogram the
mole the Kelvin and the ampere and the
other three the second
the meter and the Candela which is a
measurement of the brightness of light
we had been been redefined in much the
same way earlier gotcha so let's go into
more detail about how each of these
units will be defined currently the
kilogram is defined as the mass of a
cylinder of platinum and iridium stored
in the International Bureau of weights
and measurements so how do they plan on
defining the kilogram now without this
physical reference yeah so it's tricky
and the best way to explain it is to
explain what they did in 1983 in
redefining the meter up to 1983 you had
seconds that were defined one way and
meters which are obviously different and
were defined independently to make their
definition the meter more precise they
would change things around and what they
would do is that they would define the
speed of light to have a precise value
right so there would be no uncertainty
in it anymore
so they set the speed of light is a
constant exact number and then they were
able to turn the meter into something
that you could actually go out and
measure and that would be the standard
meter so they're doing something very
similar with the kilogram except that
they're defining constant called
Planck's constant which shows up in
quantum mechanics and basically if
people are familiar with it at all it's
because the energy of a photon or a
quantum of light is given by Planck's
constant times the frequency of the
photon and it turns out that if you
define clocks constant then you can turn
things around and you can measure out an
absolute kilogram with essentially an
electrical balance and so you would
replace this one slug of
platinum-iridium which is the kilogram
with these electrical balances of which
there are a few around the world so now
instead of defining the kilogram by this
physical reference they're dividing it
in terms of Planck's constant that's
right that's completely right but how is
this gonna change in terms of
experimentation and measuring things out
I mean it's gonna be pretty complicated
right it is pretty tremendously
complicated even the people who were
involved in this admit that it's
complicated rate so the speed of light
thing is pretty easy right you know you
get this idea okay if I define the speed
then you know all I need to do is figure
out how far light travels in particular
given time and then
got the meter but these so-called kibble
balances that are used to measure out
the kilogram are a lot more complicated
but the fact is that if you have a
kibble balance right and it's well tuned
you can knock out a standard kilogram
weight very easily right so this makes
the system much more flexible because
you don't just have that single
reference if you have a well-defined
kibble balance you can make your own
reference weights and so that's the idea
behind this did people have other
propositions on how to redefine the
kilogram well there are other ways that
you could conceive of doing this right I
mean you could conceive of saying I'm
going to define the mass of the
carbon-12 atom to be some tiny fraction
of a kilogram and therefore a kilogram
is equal to the mass of some gigantic
number of carbon-12 atoms the reason
they didn't do that one is that counting
up all those atoms is really really hard
and the other reason was exactly because
the kibble balance works by bringing in
these quantum devices to measure
electrical resistances and voltages and
those techniques are exquisitely precise
but they're not actually part of the SI
right there's sort of these techniques
that have been invented outside the SI
and have ever been brought in I mean
some people have complained that the
redefinition is going to be really
confusing and really hard to get your
arms around but there are sort of
specific practical reasons that they did
it this way so now moving on to some
other units that are planned to be
redefined what's going to happen with
the Kelvin
the degree Kelvin which is the absolute
temperature scale it used to be that
there's one very specific temperature
called the triple point of water in
which water liquid vapour and solid can
all coexist and that temperature was
defined as 273 point one six Kelvin and
so if you wanted to determine what a
Calvin was you had to set up an
experiment that held water at that
temperature and then you would divide
whatever temperature you got however you
were going to measure it by 273 and now
what they've done is they've just find
this thing called Boltzmann's constant
which always relates to say the
temperature of a material to the amount
of thermal energy in it if you know
Boltzmann's constant you work through a
bunch of math and you can
get the temperature and the beauty of
that system is that it's no longer tied
to the specific temperature where the
definition would be most accurate who
are the proponents for these changes and
who are the people that are kind of
pushing back and saying this could cause
a lot of confusion maybe we should think
of another way to redefine it this has
really come out of the metrology
community right they have developed this
consensus that this is much more
reliable system but that said even the
people who are strongly for this and who
have been working for more than a decade
to get the precise measurements of the
constants that you'll need to fix them
they admit or acknowledge that this is
going to be a little bit tough on people
right people generally learn about units
and weights and all that in middle
school right and it's pretty easy to
understand if a meter is the length of a
meter stick and a kilogram as a weighted
particular weight but when it's tied to
some constant in quantum physics that
people have never heard of it's going to
be a little bit harder for them to get
their heads around yeah it takes a lot
more background knowledge to even
understand that so if those changes well
like you said they most likely will be
approved how long will it take for them
to be implemented everybody I spoke to
is pretty sure that this is going to
happen one researcher told me that
they've already they've already
scheduled the party so it seems likely
that this is it is going to go through
but the the world would get about six
months get used to the the new idea it
must be said most of us never deal with
this we don't worry about what have a
second is to find or how how a metre is
defined right because the value itself
isn't changing its just the
conceptualization behind it so it's not
like people are gonna have to go buy new
like scales or anything like that right
that's absolutely right so what they did
is that they put in well more than a
decade worth of effort to try to measure
the different constants that they're
going to fix now to exquisite precision
because once you fix them there's kind
of no going back Planck's constant will
have this exact value and so they
couldn't have five groups around the
world measuring this thing with wildly
different numbers right now they all had
to converge this was actually supposed
to happen back in 2014 and General
Conference on weights and measures then
at this and said that the numbers
weren't quite ready they weren't quite
ready to fix the constants and so now
apparently they are so that's why this
is happening now yeah so this has been
an undertaking that's been going on for
many years but are there more changes on
the horizon after this big one what's
next
a foot is a reconsideration of the
definition of the second in principle it
will still be defined as some gigantic
multiple of the oscillations of
radiation from a particular atom but
just which atomic transition is used in
which frequency of light is going to be
changed that may happen as as soon as is
2030 it's not for a little while it's
gonna be awhile but at the same time you
know obviously science keeps growing and
one of the things that the folks who do
this this sort of work have to be open
to is of course people invent new units
right the metric system was born shortly
after the the French Revolution and the
committee in France got together and
they defined the meter in the kilogram
but back then those were the units right
all these other things have come have
come since then right all right thank
you so much Adrian my pleasure Meghan
Adrienne Cho is a staff writer at
science you can find a link to his piece
at science bag org slash
podcasts and that concludes this edition
of the science podcast if you have any
comments or suggestions for the show
write to us at science podcast at AAA
SOR G you can subscribe to the show
anywhere you get your podcasts or you
can listen on the science website that
science bagged org slash podcasts to
place an ad on the science podcast
contact mid-roll comm the show is
produced by Sarah Crespi and Megan
Cantwell and edited by pod achee jeffrey
cook composed the music on behalf of
science magazine and it's publisher
triple-a us thanks for joining us